[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
الرياض وواشنطن ترحبان باتفاق الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع على تمديد
الهدنه خمسه ايام
في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا مسيرات تغلق
اجواء كياب واتفاقيه حبوب في مهب رياح عدم
التجديد
[موسيقى]
بين متغنن بانجازاته ومعترض على سياساته
اردوغان الرئيس امام تحديات الانقسام
والاقتصاد
من الارض الى الفضاء الصين ترسل اول رائد
فضاء مدني الى محطتها تيانغونج وايلون
ماسك هذا الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه البدايه من
التطورات الحرب في السودان حيث اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه موافقه الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع على تمديد
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار لمده خمسه ايام
واوضح مكتب الشؤون الافريقيه بوزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان ان السعوديه
والولايات المتحده باعتبارهما طرفين
المسيرين للمفاوضات بين طرفي الصرع
السوداني ترحبان بالاتفاق على تمديد
الهدنه واشار البيان الى ان الاتفاق من
شانه ان يتيح الوقت لتقديم المزيد من
المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه
ومناقشه تمديد محتمل لمده اطول
معنى من جده مديره مكتب العربيه في
السودان لما يعقوب لينا اهلا بك المزيد من
تفاصيل هذا التمديد الجديد للهدى في
السودان
مساء الخير عليك صهيب هذه الهدنه مددت كما
هي بذات البنود الوارده فيها لمده خمسه
ايام في خلال الخمسه ايام سيتم بحث ونقاش
بعض الفروقات التي وردت في هذه الهدنه
والتي حددتها الوساطه في وقت سابق هناك
فروقات من جانب الجيش وخروقات من جانب
الدعم السريع ولكن الحديث سيكون معنيا
بصوره اكبر للمواطن في خلال الخمسه ايام
المقبله هناك حديث عن دخول بعض المساعدات
الانسانيه وبعض الادويه للمستشفيات التي
لا يتواجد فيها الدعم السريع لذلك ستكون
هناك نقاشات بصوره اكبر على ضروره خروج
الدعم السريع من المستشفيات وعدم احتلال
المنازل واخلاء المرافق العامه والخاصه
التي يتواجد فيها على الجانب الاخر هناك
ايضا مطالبات للجيش بوقف القصف واستهداف
مواقع الدعم السريع وكذلك الطائرات
والمسيرات التي تعتبر بحسب البيان انها
خرقي الهدنه لذلك سيكون هناك نقاش حول هذه
النقاط خلال الايام المق
لنا يعقوب مباشره من جده
انتهاك هو اتفاقيه وقفه اطلاق النار قد
يعصف بمصير ملايين السودانيين فعمليه
توصيل المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله يصطدم
باستمرار المواجهات المسلحه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع منظمه الامم
المتحده بدوريها دخلت على الخط على هذه خط
هذه الدعوات لاحترام الهدى للانسانيه
والسماحي بايصال المساعدات الامم المتحده
قالت انه على الرغم من اتفاق الهدنه الا
انها تكافح من اجل الحصول على موافقات
وضمانات امنيه بغيت وصول المساعدات وفرق
الاغاثه الى الاماكن المحتاجه
وان كانت الخرطوم قد شهدت توقفا ولو
متقطعا لاطلاق النار فان الوضع مختلف
تماما
غرب
فالمع دون اي التزام من اي طرف بوقف اطلاق
النار فعلكم مستمره الزمت الوضع الانساني
الذي بات مقلقا الى درجه كبيره في ظل
تدمير البنيه التحتيه الحيويه ما ادى الى
حرمان الكثيرين من الوصول الى الغذاء
والمياه النظيفه والادويه كما ان الخطر
بات محدقا بالمدنيين العزل الذين قاموا
بحفر الخنادق حول احيائهم ووضعوا الحواجز
لابعاد المقاتلين
شبحوا الكارثه الانسانيه باتا يحوم اذا
حول دارفور اكثر من اي منطقه اخرى في
السودان والوضع مرشح لايزداد سوءا وهو ما
حذرت منه منظمات امميه مثل مفوضيه الامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين بالسودان التي
اكدتنا هناك تجاهلا صارخا لاتفاقيه وقف
اطلاق النار في اقليم دارفور كما اضافت ان
الاف النازحين السودانيين لم يتلقوا اي
مساعدات منذ اربعين يوما بسبب القتال
المستمر
معنى من القاهره الصحفيه والمحلل السياسي
حمر زياده استاذ حمور اهلا بكم معنا في
اخبار الساعه ابدا معك من التمديد الجديد
للهدنه في السودان بين الجيش والدعم
السريع بوساطه سعوديه امريكيه كيف تقيم
بدايه الهدنه السابقه
الخدمه السابقه في تقدير لم تاتي يعني
غرضها لم تؤدي هذا الغرض الذي وقعت من
اجلها المساعدات الانسانيه لم تصل الى
المواطنين الدعم السريع الذي يحتل
المستشفيات لم يخرج منها
القصف
بطيران الجيش السوداني استمر هذه كلها
كانت يعني نقاط وردت في اتفاق المبادئ وفي
اتفاقيه الهدنه لكن تم خرقها باشكال
متفاوته وهذا بحسب ما ورد في بيان الاليه
وعلى حسب ما نرى على الارض في تقدير الان
ان هذه
التمديد الجديد
للهدنه يجب ان يراعي هذه الخروقات وان
يحاول ان ينفذ شيئا ما من الجيد
هذه علامه استفهام يعني توقيع اكثر من
اثنتين عشره هدنه والان تمديد الان لهدنه
اخرى بنفس النموذج مع تسجيل دائما نفس
الخروقات وعدم صمود لهذه الهدن كيف يفسر
عدم الوصول الى اي نقطه بين الطرفين للبحث
عن مخرج الحديث فقط ما يزال يتم على
الحاجات الانسانيه والصحيه فقط
الطرفان ليس لديهما رغبه في انهاء هذا
الامر بشكل تفاوضي يعني هذا اعتقد انه امر
واضح وما كل طرف ما زال يسعى الى انتصار
عسكري هذا الامر ايضا واضح في تصريحات
الوساطه التي تكرر اكثر من مره انه لا
يمكن ان يكون هناك حل عسكري لهذه الازمه
تكرار هذه الاشارات يعني انهم يسمعون
بوضوح ويرون بشكل جلي من تصرفات الطرفين
انهما مصممان على استمرار المعارك رغم
خضوعهما للضغوطات بالجلوس للتفاوض في جده
وتوقيع اتفاقيات هدن لا يلتزمان بها انا
اعتقد انه الان الضغط سيكون على الميسرين
ودول الوساطه ان تحاول بشكل اكبر ان تجبر
الطرفين على الالتزام بالهدنه وهو من
الواضح السؤال هناك هناك رغبه يمكن الدفع
بالطرفين بالجيش والدعم السريع الى التحا
ور حول انهاء القتال بدل البحث عن هدى لا
تصمد كما تفضلت ويتم خرقها من الطرفين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه من الواضح انهما يضغطان
بكرت العقوبات كما صرحت اليوم الخارجيه
الامريكيه العقوبات الشخصيه اضافه الى
العلاقات مع الطرفين يضغطان من اجل على
القيادات من اجل المزيد من الالتزام بهذه
الهدنه واعتقد يعني كما كنت احاول ان اقول
قبل قليل ان هذا لعب الان يقع عليهما لان
الطرفان يوقعان على الهدى ولا يستجيبان
لها لذلك لا بد من مزيد من الضغوط هذه
الكروت التي تملكها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والتي تملكها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اضافه للضغط الشعبي المحلي
الرافض للحرب هي ما يمكن ان تجبر الطرفين
على وقف اطلاق النار شكرا جزيلا لكم
الصحفي والمحلل السياسيه حمور زياده كنتم
معنا مباشره من القاهره
[موسيقى]
تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا فقد اطلقت روسيا
عشرات الصواريخ والمسيره على العاصمه كييف
السلطات الاوكرانيه اعلنت للتصدي للهجمات
فيما اظهرت مقاطع متداوله اعتراض دفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه صواريخ روسيه في سماء
كي
[موسيقى]
الجيش الروسي اعلن استهدافها مراكز
القياده ومعدات طيران ومخازن اسلحه وذخيره
اوكرانيه بضربات جويه على المطارات
الاوكرانيه خلال الليل اشجار المتحدث باسم
الدفاع الروسيه
كانت باسلحه بعيده المدى وموجهه بدقه
وحققت اهدافها
نفذت القوات المسلحه الروسيه الليله
الماضيه ضربه جماعيه باسلحه جويه بعيده
المدى موجهه بدقه ضد اهداف معاديه في
المطارات الاوكرانيه تم تحقيق هدف الضربه
الجويه وتدمير كل الاهداف نتيجه الضربه تم
تدمير مراكز القياده ومراكز الرادار وكذلك
معدات الطيران ومرافق تخزين اسلحه وذخائر
تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه
من جانبه اكد مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني في تصريحات للعربيه ان الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد لا يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه
واحده بل سلسله من العمليات الجاريه مشيرا
الى ان بعض عمليات الهجوم جاريه منذ عده
اسابيع
اما فيما يخص هجومنا ولم يحصل الان فهذا
غير صحيح لان الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد لا
يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه واحده في الساعه
معينه ثم نراها على شاشه التلفزيون هذه
الهجمات المضاده هي سلسله من العمليات
الصغيره والكبيره والبعض منها جاريه منذ
عده اسابيع
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني انه ينبغي انشاء
منطقه منزوعه السلاح بعمق يتراوح بين 100
و120 كيلومترا داخل روسيا بطول حدودها مع
اوكرانيا وذلك في اطار اي تسويه بعد الحرب
حسب ما كتب في تغريده له على تويتر اضاف
ان المنطقه الحدوديه منزوعه السلاح داخل
روسيا يجب ان تخضع لاشراف دولي
معنى من كياب الصحفيه محمد البابا محمد
اهلا بك معنا عما اسفر قصف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كياف وهل ما تزال حاله الخوف
والذعر مستمره حتى الان
نعم يعني خلال اليومين الاخيرين تصاعد
الهجوم الصاروخي وبالمسيرات على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه وليله امس كانت صاخبه حيث كان
هناك هجوم ويعني مختلف انواع الاسلحه
بصواريخ ومسيرات على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
استكمل هذا الهجوم بهجوم في ساعه يعني في
ساعه ذروه الظهر عندما تم اطلاق عشر او
احد عشر صاروخ باليستي على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه صواريخ من نوع اسكندر تم
اسقاطها فوق سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
بفعل الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه هناك
استنفار عام للجيش الاوكراني تحسبا لاي
هجوم صاروخ محتمل هذه الليله على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه التي تعيش اجواء يعني قاسيه
خلال الفتره الاخيره هناك حاله من الذعر
من المواطنين ولكن هذا الظهر مصاحب يعني
طمانه من الجيش الاوكراني التي يعني يعلن
يعني قياده الجيش الاوكراني ان الدفاعات
الجويه كانت يعني تقوم بعملها بشكل كامل
في حمايه العاصمه الاوكرانيه يعني الاهداف
خاصه ان القصف يوم يعني فيه
محمد انه حتى الان لهذه الليله لا يوجد
قصف حتى الان يعني
حتى هذه اللحظه عاده القصف والانذار الجوي
ياتي بعد الساعه يعني بعد حوالي ساعتين من
الان ان كان سيحصل خاصه في ثلاثه ليالي
الماضيه كانت صاخبه كان هناك هجوم على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف وعلى مدن اخرى
ولكن يعني كان هناك رساله كبيره من عمده
مدينه كييف في تالي كليتشكو الذي وجه سؤال
الى قائد القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
فاليريزالوجني قال فيه لماذا سكان
روسيا يعني تضغط على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ولماذا سكان موسكو لا يعيشون منذ سنه ونصف
ما يعيشه سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف في
رساله من عمده الى قائد القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بضروره ان يعيش سكان موسكو ما
يعيشه سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف محمد
البابا من كييف شكرا جزيلا
شكرا
[موسيقى]
هل يطل شبح وازمه الحبوب من جديد ليدخل
العالم في ازمه غذائيه جديده سؤال طفى على
السطح مجددا بعد تداول تلميحات قادمه من
موسكو فالعديد من المسؤولين الروس هددوا
مرارا بالانسحاب من اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه مشتكين من وجود عقبات امام
تصدير روسيا للاسمده وللحبوب اخر هذه
التحضيرات تصريح وزير الخارجيه الروسي
الذي حذر من انهيار اتفاق الحبوب اذا لم
يتم تحقيق مصالح روسيا
مبادره البحر الاسود فيما يتعلق بتصدير
المنتجات الاوكرانيه والحبوب وغيرها من
الموانئ الاوكرانيه علقنا عليها مرارا
وتكرارا اعتقد انه من ثلاثين مليون طن تم
تصديرها اقل من ثلاثه في المئه
ذهبت الى افقر البلدان مذكره التفاهم بين
روسيا والامم المتحده لم يتم الوفاء بها
على الاطلاق لدينا امكانيات لتصدير
منتجاتنا الزراعيه بتجاوز هذا التفاهم مع
الامم المتحده لكن طبعا اذا نجح الامين
العام للامم المتحده في تنفيذ كل ما يدعو
اليه وما تم الاتفاق عليه في المذكره
سيكون لهذا اثر ايجابي على اسواق الحبوب
والسماد فيما يتعلق بمصير مبادره البحر
الاسود فقد تحدثنا عن ذلك فيما سبق اذا
بقي كل شيء كما هو ويبدو انه سيظل كذلك
فسيكون من الضروري لانطلاق من حقيقه انه
لم تعد المبادره فعاله
روسيا تتحفظ على اليه تطبيق اتفاقيه
الحبوب الاوكرانيه رغم موافقتها على
تمديدها قبل ايام فوزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
قالت ان تقييمها المبدئيه الاتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب لم يتغير داعيه الى تصحيح اوجه
الخلل في تنفيذها في اقرب وقت ممكن ووفق
الاتفاقيه لا تخضع الصادرات الروسيه من
المواد الغذائيه والاسمده للعقوبات
الغربيه غير ان موسكو تقول ان القيود على
المدفوعات والخدمات اللوجستيه والتامين
تشكل عائقا امام الشحنات في المقابل ترفض
الولايات المتحده الشكاوى الروسيه وتقول
ان موسكو تصدر الحبوب والاسمده بنفس
المستويات التي كانت من قبل الحرب
الاوكرانيه وربما اكثر
ومجرد تلويح روسيا بامكانيه انسحابها من
اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب كان كافيا لبث القلق
في الكثير من المناطق حول العالم فكل من
اوكرانيا وروسيا تنتجان حوالي 30% من
صادرات القمح العالميه وذلك الى حدود
بدايه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في فبراير
من السنه الماضيه وكان انخفاض شحنات
الحبوب الاوكرانيه قد ادى الى ازمه اسعار
عالميه كما ان برنامج الغذاء العالمي
التابع للامم المتحده كان قد نال الشهر
الماضي قال ان انعدام الامن الغذائي لا
يزال عند مستويات غير مسبوقه واضاف ان اي
تعليق للاتفاقيه قد يؤدي الى قفزه في
الاسعار العالميه للحبوب
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه وزير الداخليه
اللبنانيه يؤكد للعربيه ان المواطن
السعودي المختطف بخير ويتوعدوا بمحاسبه
المنفلين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الانتخابات التركيه تصدر
ستارها اذا وتنهي لعبه التشويق والاثاره
معلنه عن اردوغان رئيسا لتركيا لولايه
ثالث كلمه الحسم كانت لزعيم حزب العداله
والتنميه الذي انها احلام منافسه
وتفوق عليه في الجوله الثانيه اردوغان
اضاف خمس سنوات لولايته معززا مكانه كاطول
زعيم بقاء في السلطه في تركيا منذ اعلانها
جمهوريه رئيس تركي كسب الرهان رغم ان فتره
ولايته الاخيره سجلت تراجعا في المجال
الاقتصادي وتقهرا واضحا لليره التركيه
الازمه الاقتصاديه نزلت بثقلها على الوضع
المعيشي في تركيا خلال فتره اردوغان وتصدر
التضخم المرتفع تصدر قائمه الازمات
العنيفه التي واجهت الاتراك خلال ولايه
اردوغان حيث سجل مستوى قياسيا تجاوز 85%
خلال اكتوبر الماضي وهبطت الليره التركيه
اكثر من 7% منذ بدايه العام كما خسرت اكثر
من 90% من قيمتها خلال العقد الماضي وحسب
تقرير لصحيفه لوصلي جورنال فقد تسبب
النزول الكبير لقيمه الليره التركيه مقابل
الدولار الامريكي الى تراجع الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه في تركيا
ونهايه ولايه اردوغان الثانيه شهدت حدثا
ماساويا تمثل في الزلزال المدمر الذي هز
جنوب البلاد شهر فبراير الماضي زلزال اودى
بحياه ما لا يقل عن 50 الف شخص فضلا عن
تدمير 173 الف مبنى واكد الزلزال يتسبب
فيها ذات سياسيه من شانها الاطاحه
باردوغان الذي تجاوز اثار الزلزال رغم
الاصوات المنتقده التي تعالت في بعض
الفترات احتجاجا على ما وصفت بضعف في
الاستجابه من قبل الحكومه في التعاطي مع
مخلفات الزلزال
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التركي حافظ على كرسي الرئاسه اذا
رغم المنافسه الشرسه مع زعيم المعارضه
كمالك فرغم اللجوء الى جوله ثانيه الا ان
صناديق الاقتراع ابتسمت في الاخير
لاردوغان فما هي يا ترى العوامل التي
ساعدت اردوغان على البقاء في منصبه رئيس
تركيا مشاهدينا اتخذ العديد من الاجراءات
قبيل الانت رئاسيه لاستقطاب الناخبين فقد
اعلن عن
ان يتم
تزويد المواطنين الاتراك بغاز طبيعي مجاني
كما قرر رفع رواتب موظفي القطاع العام
بنسبه 45% بعد زياده اوليه في وقت سابق من
هذا العام دون ان ننسى اطلاق خطه لاعاده
الاعمار الواسعه والسريعه للمناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال
وبعد ان هدات الفرحه فرحه الفوز في
الانتخابات سيكون اردوغان مدعوا لمواجهه
التحديات العديده التي تواجهها بلاده
البدايه ستكون بمواجهه شبح التضخم والحفاظ
على استقرار الاقتصاد الذي يعاني من نقص
خطير في الدولار اردوغان لم يتاخر في
تقديم التطمينات بشان التضخم الذي يعصف
بالبلاد ووصف اردوغان ملف التضخم بالقضيه
الاكثر الحاحا لتركيا معتبرا ان حلها ليس
بالصعب اما فيما يتعلق بملف اللاجئين
السوريين فقد كان اردوغان واضحا بشكل كافي
من خلال تاكيده مره اخرى على تامين عوده
مليون لاجئ سوري اضافي وعلى المستوى
الخارجي يبدو بان موقف اردوغان سيكون اكثر
قوه بعد ضمانه الاستمرار لخمس سنوات
اضافيه وهو ما يجعل تغيير سياسته الخارجيه
بشكل جذري امرا
وخلال عقدين من اعتلاء السلطه في تركيا
كيف بدا اردوغان سياسته مطلع الالفيه وكيف
تحولت سياساته بعد انقلاب الخامس عشر من
تموز يوليو عام 2016 اليوم ومع بدايه
ولايه جديده هل يعتبر اردوغان وفقا
لسياساته اسلاميا عن قوميا ام اتاتوركا
بين هذه المشاهد وتلك اكثر من عقدين من
الزمن وكثير من التحولات لسياسه الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان تحولات يقول
كثيرون ان هذه الصور كانت الفيصله فيها
على تركيا وعلى محيطها
فمنذ المحاوله الانقلابيه في صيف 2016 سلك
الرجل طريق الانفتاح ليس على الداخل فحسب
بل الخارج ايضا
منذ بدايه العقد الاخير فتح الرجل ابواب
بلده للجماعه وقياداتها لا سيما بعد
فرارهم من مصر وسوريا غير انه عاد وقرر
نجم الجماعه ومنصاتها الاعلاميه عقب مد يد
التقارب مع مصر وحتى مع النظام السوري
بشكل ما
خلال الاعوام الماضيه شهدت العلاقات
التركيه توترا واصل الى ما يشبه القطيعه
مع دول خليجيه لكن اردوغان عاد لاصلاح
العلاقات ماخوذا بالمصلحه التركيه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
خلال الاشهر الماضيه لم يخفي اردوغان
رغبته بلقاء بشار الاسد والتعاون معه حتى
وصلت الاوضاع حد تشكيل اللجنه مشتركه
للتطبيع واعاده اللاجئين الى المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها الحكومه السوريه
شكل القوميون حجر الزاويه في تحالفات
اردوغان الداخليه والانتخابيه
فالتحالف مع حزب الحركه القوميه مكن الرجل
من حسم التحول الى النظام الرئاسي عام
والانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2018
تحالفات اختتمها اردوغان مع القومي
المتشدد سنان اوجان للفوز بالانتخابات
الاخيره
اردوغان الفائز اليوم وان احتفظ بخطابه
الديني الثقافي اليوم الا انه لم يعد بحسب
الكثيرين اردوغان الاسلامي بل اردوغان
القومي اتى تركيا رغما عن الاتاتوركين
بعيدا عن خطاب مطلع الالفيه والتغيير لكن
دائما امبرغماتيا فالواقع يقول
اردوغان اليوم غير اردوغان الامس
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان القاعده
المعروفه في تركيا بانه ما يربح اسطنبول
يربح كامله تركيا لكن في جوله الاعاده كما
في الجوله الاولى خسر اردوغان في اسطنبول
وفي انقره كذلك فما هي اسباب التراجع في
المدن الكبرى التفاصيل في تقرير زيدان
كلوب من القرن
فاز الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بولايه رئاسيه
جديده لكنه خسر اسطنبول وانقره اكبر
مدينتين في تركيا وهو ما اثار السؤال حول
اسباب تراجع الرئيس في كبرى المدن التقينا
برهان مدير احد اكبر مراكز الاستطلاعات في
العاصمه انقره لمعرفه اسباب التراجع وفق
برهان فان نظام التحالفات الذي بدا العمل
به في انتخابات 2018
اثر سلبا على اصوات اردوغان في المدن
الكبرى على سبيل المثال في اسطنبول يمتلك
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الذي دعم زعيم
المعارضه اثني عشر في المئه من الناخبين
مقارنه بخمسه في المئه من ناخب حزب الحركه
القوميه الذي يدعم اردوغان لذلك خسر
اردوغان اسطنبول في سباق الرئاسه لكنه فاز
باغلبيه برلمانيه فيها
والحال ذاته ينسحب على العاصمه
الذي يضم سته احزاب دعم ايضا من قبل حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي بالنظر الى طبيعه تحالف
المعارضه المعروف باسم تحالف الامه مقارنه
بتحالف الشعب الذي يتزعمه الرئيس اردوغان
نرى ان قوه واصوات تحالف المعارضه في
المدن الكبرى افضل مقارنه بتحالف الشعب
هناك راي اخر يقول ان اردوغان الرئيس
القوي المنشغله باعباء الرئاسه والسياسه
الخارجيه لا يوجد من يوازيه في حزبه بنفس
القوه والقدره على الاقناع لمخاطبه الشارع
لدى حزب العداله فريق يعمل في الدعايه
والتواصل مع الجماهير لكن يلاحظوا وجود
تقاعس في بعض الاحيان وعدم وجود قدره على
الاقناع بقدر قوه الرئيس اردوغان في احيان
اخرى
[موسيقى]
قالت السفاره السعوديه في لبنان انها تلقت
بلاغا من ذوي احد المواطنين الذي فقد
الاتصال به فجرا الاحد واضافت السفاره
السعوديه في بيان انها تتواصل مع السلطات
اللبنانيه لكشف ملابسات اختفاء المواطن
السعودي في لبنان وفي مقابله مع العربيه
قال وزير الداخليه اللبنانيه بسام المولوي
ان القوى الامنيه اللبنانيه تتابع بدقه
موضوعا لمواطن السعودي المختطف في لبنان
مضيفا ان السعوديه المختطف بخير واكد انه
يتم اطلاع السفير السعودي في بيروت على كل
التطورات بشكل فوري
هذا الموضوع تتابعه القوى الامنيه بكل
حرفيه ومهنيه
ويجري التواصل بطبيعه الحال مع السفير
السعودي مع معالي السفير وليد البخاري
لاجل متابعه الموضوع ولاجل اطلاعه على ما
يلزم من تفاصيل وعلى ما
تحصل عليه القوى الامنيه نحن علينا متابعه
الموضوع هذا موضوع لا نقبل به هذا موضوع
يمس بعلاقه لبنان بالدول العربيه الشقيقه
وراسيما بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه ان امن
وامان كافه المقيمين على الاراضي
اللبنانيه ولا سيما المواطنين العرب
والمواطنين من من مواطني دول الخليج
العربي ومواطنين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هم اشقاء وان امنهم وامانهم مهم جدا
للبنان ولعلاقته ولعلاقه لبنان بهذه الدول
الشقيقه
واضاف الوزير ان السلطات الامنيه رصد
التحرك هاتف المواطن السعودي المختطف في
اكثر من منطقه وشدد على سريه التحقيق الى
حين التوصل لكافه ملابسات عمليه الاختطاف
وتوعد بمحاسبه المنفذ
معلومات لديك او لدى
الاعلام تقول بانه تم رصد
مكالمات او رسائل هاتفيه من اكثر من منطقه
هذا يعني ان
هاتف المواطن السعودي يتنقل بين اكثر من
منطقه في بيروت وهذا يدل على
عمل معين لدى الفاعلين وهذا يستوجب على
القوه الامنيه اللبنانيه ان تكون على قدر
كبير من الحيطه ومن الحذر وان تتعامل مع
الموضوع بدقه بالغه
ينبغي لسلامه التحقيق
ولسريه التحقيق الواجبه للوصول الى نتيجه
ولسلامه المواطن السعودي طبعا وهي الاهم
ان نلتزم بحد معين من سريه التحقيق
لجلاء كافه الملابسات
الى مشاهدينا قبل ان نذهب الى فاصل اذا
بيان سعودي امريكي عن تمديد الهدنه ووقف
اطلاق النار في السودان هو يتيح المزيد من
الوقت اذا للعمليات الانسانيه يقول البيان
السعودي الامريكيه المشترك حول تمديد
الهدنه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع بعد الفاصل في اخبار الساعه
الفوضى والعنف يتصدران المشهد في شمالي
كوسوفو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام المزيد
من التفاصيل ترد حول البيان السعودي
الامريكي حول تمديد الهدنه في السودان
البيان يقول ان تمديد وقفه اطلاق النار
بالسوداني ياتي لاتاحه مزيد من الوقت
للعمليات الانسانيه البيان السعوديه
الامريكيه المشترك اضافها ان وقفه اطلاق
النار طويل الامد بالسودانيه يتطلبوا
انسحاب القوات من المناطق الماهوله وكذلك
بان السعوديه وامريكا يحثان طرفي النزاعي
بالسودان على التقيد بالتزاماتهما بموجب
هذه الهدنه يقول البيان السعودي الامريكي
المشترك
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا عوده الى ملف تركيا وفوز رئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه حول
الموضوع معنا من اسطنبول استاذ العلوم
السياسيه الدكتور سمير صالحه دكتور سمير
اهلا بك معنا مع هذا الفوز لاردوغان رغم
كل التحديات والعوائق التي والصعوبات التي
كان يواجهها خلال هذا الفوز وجوله الاعاده
غير المسبوقه
يتم التساؤل الان عن كيف نجح اردوغان في
التسويق نفسه هل كم شخصيه سياسيه اسلاميه
ام كشخصيه محافظه شخصيه قوميه ام شخصيه
علمانيه اتى تركيا
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا طبعا يعني
الجذور السياسيه والحزبيه للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان مهمه يعني اذا ما عدنا الى
التسعينيات وعلى كيف تدرج في
حزب الرفاع الذي كان يقوده نجم الدين
لكن كما تعرف انت ايضا
في العام 2002 بعد الانفصال مجموعه
حزبيه بارزه في
اربكان تاسيس حزب العداله كان في مسار
جديد نفس جديد بالنسبه لي حزب العداله
والتنميه التركيز كان على ربما الخروج من
التوصيفات الكلاسيكيه التقليديه المعروفه
وقتها والذهاب وراء تاسيس حزب تركي جديد
محافظ يجمع اكثر من شريحه على مستوى
المجتمع التركي يعني يجمع الليبرالي يجمع
المسلم يجمع اليساري القومي اكثر من توجه
داخل هذا
اذا كانت
صحيح هذا ما كنت ساقوله لكن في العام 2010
بعد النقاشات التي جرت على مستوى الاقليم
كان في ايضا التوجه باتجاه لعب دور اقليمي
اوسع بالنسبه لتركيا في اطار هذه
الشعارات التي نتحدث عنها الان نظرا سريعا
اذهب الى الاستنتاج فقط الى الاستنتاج
يعني اجيب على السؤال بشكل مباشر نظره
خاطفه وسريعه انا وانت اذا القينا على
التحالف الذي وقف الى جانب الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اليوم
تحالف
التكتل الحزب الحاكم نرى فيه حزب العداله
نعم نرى الى جانبه دوله باشا القومي
اليميني نرى الى جانبه اليسار القومي يعني
في عنا شريحه واسعه سياسيه حسبيه متداخله
الان شريك للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وربما
هذا يساعدنا في الاجابه على السؤال الذي
طرحته نعم طيب دكتور سمير صالح بالنسبه
لعلاقات تركيا الان مع اردوغان في هذه
الولايه الثالثه بدانا نشهد اتصالات مصريه
تركيه كذلك بعد هذا الفوز ماذا نتوقع فيما
يتعلق بالمصالحات التركيه العربيه وكذلك
ملف اللاجئين السوريين وخاصه ملف المصالحه
مع النظام السوري
يعني يبدو لي انه في ضوء التحول في سياسات
التركي الخارجيه التي تحدثنا عنها دائما
يبدو انه في رغبه تركيه واضحه باتجاه
تسريع الحوار مع الدول الفاعله في الاقليم
المجموعه العربيه تحديدا باتجاه التنسيق
في حاله العديد من الملفات العالقه
الملفات خلافيه ملفات توتر وغيرها هذه
الصيغه الجديده في اطار حوار اقليمي بين
تركيا وهذه العواصم برايي سيتقدم سيتسارع
في المرحله المقبله كما اشرت انت هذا
الاتصال التركي المصري الذي بدا في
الاسابيع الاخيره بدا الان ينتج ثماره
احتمال اذا ان نرى هذه القمه التركيه
المصريه في اسرع ما يكون انا تابعني انا
وانت حديث رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان عن رغبته
باداء فريضه الحاج هذا الموسم هذا هل يحمل
معه سؤال انه سيكون هناك ج خليجيات تواكب
الاداء فريضه الحج ام لا هذه نقطه مهمه
خصوصا ان الرئيس اردوغان اشاد قبل ايام
بالدعم الخليجي
للعربي لتركيا الوقوف الى جانبها في
ازماتها الاقتصاديه والماليه هذا يعكس
حقيقه برايين وتركيا تعطي الاولويه في
انفتاحها او سياساتها نحوها سؤال سريع
ولكن دول العربيه كانت يعني تشتكي من
مساله دعم اردوغان لاحزاب الاسلام السياسي
في بعض الدول وما ادى الى بعض الاضطرابات
فيها هل برايك اردوغان
سيغير هذا النهج في سبيل
تحسين العلاقات مع الدول العربيه
انا عندما حدثتك عن بنيه حزب العداله
والتنميه الجديده الشركاء كنت اقصد ان
اقول لك انه هناك تحول واضح في سياسات
تركي احيال هذه المسائل هذا ما قصدته
تحديدا انه داخل التركي الان يناقش مسائل
جديده فيها الكثير من البرماتيه على
المستوى الداخل الداخلي وعلى المستوى
الخارجي صحيح انه البعض ما زال من الخارج
يحاول ان يعني يتمسك
السياسات القديمه لا اظن اطلاقا انه حزب
العداله والتنميه امام هذه التحول في
سياساته الخارجيه العربيه الاقليميه
سيعود الى كانت عليه الامور قبل عقد في
مواقفه وسياسته دكتور سمير صالحه استاذ
العلوم السياسيه مباشره من اسطنبول شكرا
جزيلا
افادت رؤيه
الصين هذا الاسبوع واوضحت مصادر لرويتورز
ان ماسك سيلتقي مسؤولين الصينيين صينيين
كبار وسيزور منشاه لشركه تسلا في شنغها
وفي خطوه هي الاولى من نوعها اعلنت الصين
ارسال الرائد فضاء مدني في مهمه ماهوله
الى محطه تيانغونج الفضائيه كانت المهمات
الفضائيه في الصين تقتصر على اعضاء الجيش
الصيني فقط رائد الفضاء الذي اختير لهذه
المهمه يدعى وهو استاذ في جامعه علوم الجو
الفضاء وسيكون رائد الفضاء المدني مسؤولا
بشكل اساسي عن دراسه ظواهر وانظمه فضائيه
جديده
ويعيش رواد الفضاء مشقات صعبه خلال الرحله
ليس فقط للجهد المبذول في المهمه انما
لشده المحظورات عليهم بسبب قوانين
الجاذبيه لا سيما الطعام فكان لابد من صنع
الغذاء في الفضاء
في فيلم رجل المريخ يزرع رائد الفضاء مات
دايمن البطاطا على سطح الكوكب الاحمر
يستخدم تربه وسمادا على كوكب ذي بيئه
معاديه وقليله الموارد تحول الخيال الى
واقع بعد سنوات قليله من العرض جهود ثمنها
مليون دولار امريكي تقودها وكاله ناسا
لايجاد حلول مبتكره لمعضله الطعام خارج
الارض فللحصول على الغذاء في الفضاء لابد
من صنع غذائي هناك في الفضاء قائمه طعام
الرواد محكمه بشروط معقده ومليئه
بالمحظورات لتشكل الخميره مكونا اساسيا
صالحا لتغذيه رواد الفضاء لالاف السنين
بحسب الخبراء فهي تحتوي على المواد
الغذائيه التي يحتاجها الانسان من الطعام
مثل البروتين والكربوهيدرات وباستخدامها
مع طابعه ثلاثيه الابعاد
يمكن تخيلوا انتاج طعام مماثل للسوشي او
اللازانيا وباستخدام لون ورائحه معينه
يمكن انتاج فاكهه الموز كما انه تم
استخدام الخميره المعدله جينيا لانتاج
الخبز والمعكرونه فيما يطور مختبر في
فلوريدا نظاما حيويا لتربيه الخضروات
الطازجه والفطر ويرقات الحشرات لاستخدامها
كمغذيات دقيقه بالاضافه لجهود زراعه الخس
والملفوف واللفت والفلفل الحار لتكون هذه
الاغذيه اكثر شهيه هذا النظام الغذائي لا
يترك النفايات في الفضاء ويعظم قدرات
انتاج الغذاء خارج الارض بحسب الخبراء
يوما ما يقول العلماء سيعيش البشر في
اماكن بعيده عن كوكبنا الام وستكون امامهم
فرصه لبدايه جديده
ربما بطعام جديد
نذهب الان الى شمال كوسوفو حيث اصيب نحو
25 عنصرا من قوه حفظ السلام بقياده الناتو
في كوسوفو خلال مواجهات مع متظاهرين الصرب
طالبوا بمنع رؤساء بلديات منتخبين من تولي
مناصبهم فقالت القوه المتعدده الجنسيات ان
العديد من الجنود في الكاتبتين الايطاليه
والمجريه تعرضوا لهجمات غير مبرره واصيب
بكسور وحروق بسبب انفجار عبوه حارقه ومن
جانبها قالت هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون
الصربيه الحكوميه ان اكثر من 50 صربيا
اصيبوا خلال هذه الاشتباكات واصيب اثنان
بجروح خطره ويوجد مصاب في حاله حرجه
مشاهدينا بهذا التطور بين صربيا وكوسوفو
اذا تنتهي اخبار الساعه لهذه الليله شكرا
على المشاهده المزيد دائما على العربيه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات